Family and friends of our graduates,
I present to you the graduating class of 2018
from UCLA's College of Letters and Science
In the 99 year history of the
University of California at Los Angeles,
you are the most talented and most accomplished
and best-looking class to ever graduate.
As we depart from our beloved home at
UCLA, I encourage you all to think about
how you have impacted your communities on campus.
The cloudless skies and 75 degree days
will never change,
but something you did, something you participated in,
or a time when you exhibited leadership has
influenced the climate of our campus for the better.
More than anything, I hope that your experience at UCLA
has opened up some windows to the world
and leaves you yearning to know more.
Your undergraduate experience,
obviously it's just the beginning,
this is a commencement exercise
not a graduation exercise.
It's a life of continuing discovery.
Hopefully the skills you've acquired here,
the knowledge inside and outside the classroom
will serve you well in a rapidly changing world.
Bachelors, turn your tassels.
Congratulations!  Go Bruins!